Lyndon Johnson was somebody who while we
hear talk today about liberating people
we know that Lyndon Johnson liberated
the American people he liberated us from
hate and prejudice discrimination and he
helped us overcome he liberated senior
Americans by enacting Medicare and he
liberated young Americans by passing
head start and so many other education
programs he was a great progressive
president so it's my honor to be here
when I was in the White House in my
office a small office in the West Wing a
mirrored office that used to be the
barbershop I had a picture of Lyndon
Johnson there the whole time getting a
haircut
and I also want to acknowledge my wife
Jackie who was here who was the director
of the White House Fellows Program
during the Clinton administration a
program founded by President Johnson
great program that has brought gifted
people in their early careers into
public service in the executive branch
and they have gone on to distinguished
lives across our country ranging from
Tom Johnson whose remains involved in
this institution to Colin Powell who is
a secretary of state today and wesley
clark who was our supreme commander of
nato during the kosovo war so I'm
delighted to be here to speak about the
Clinton presidency the Clinton
presidency is in the line of great
progressive presidents that is how I
describe it in this book the Clinton
wars and the reason that the Clinton
presidency was surrounded by controversy
and contention by legends in myth and
even malice in my view is that Bill
Clinton had a program for bringing the
country forward and that program aroused
intense hostile opposition those issues
are alive today they still continue and
that is why even today the very name of
President Clinton arouses polarization
on two sides there are those who love
him and those who hate him the Clinton
wars are something like the Punic Wars
of the Peloponnesian wars they're
endless series of wars that will be
recounted I believe through human
history and they were about whether or
not we would move forward or whether we
would move back and great power was
contended for
them Bill Clinton when he came into
office and was elected was required to
reanimate this progressive tradition it
had been almost 30 years since the
Johnson presidency and before that the
Kennedy presidency and in that time
there had been only one Democratic
president jimmy carter a good man caught
in bad times he had been a one-term
president new realities had been created
President Clinton had to deal with the
discredit that had fallen upon the
Democratic Party as a result of
divisions over the Vietnam War over
racial strife and over the fact that the
Democratic Party is the party that
believes that the instrument of the
federal government can be used to
benefit the vast majority of the
American people and government itself
had fallen into discredit ronald reagan
in nineteen eighty in his inaugural
address had said government is not the
solution government is the problem that
was a direct contradiction of the great
progressive tradition in our history
bill clinton had to deal with new
realities he was the first president of
his generation my generation to be
elected to office he was the first
president after the Cold War as the
world could no longer be defined by the
bipolar conflict the long Twilight
Struggle and had to be reinvented so he
had to deal with his own party with the
country that was not used to a
Democratic president yet had elected
Bill Clinton with forty-three percent of
the vote in a divided field of three
candidates and with the world that
required defining itself his attempt to
change the order of things led many
Republicans in the beginning to regard
him as illegitimate as a usurper as an
interloper they believed that the
Republicans were the proper party of
government at least of holding power and
that the Republicans held a lock on the
White House and that Bill Clinton
himself did
belong there at all and from the
beginning the Clinton wars were waged
this stirred strong passions on all
sides the focus came to be on Bill
Clinton as a person but the reason that
he was personified as something that was
negative by his opposition was because
of his program the first Clinton war
took place from 1992 to 1994 it was the
lay of the political land was that the
right wing movement the conservative
movement had invested heavily in its
infrastructure particularly in
Washington and throughout the country it
had vast resources and fundraising and
money and it was beginning to create its
own media Fox News began then funded by
a Rupert Murdoch and the congressional
Democrats themselves though still the
majority party were deeply divided and
also complacent this was the kind of
party that was described by Will Rogers
I'm I'm not a member of any organized
political party I'm a Democrat
and these Democrats believe that they
could take any position and that somehow
the Democrats would always remain in the
majority in the Congress and so Bill
Clinton was a study of growth in office
in his early presidency he believed that
he could subcontract his foreign policy
to his national security team and focus
himself like laser as he said on the
economy and instead as always happens
with president's foreign policy crises
arise and Clinton was confronted by
crises in Bosnia Somalia and Haiti and
they seemed to overwhelm him at the
beginning there were stumbles in
appointments and there were also
stumbles over the initial health care
program his signature program on which
he had campaigned universal health care
Hilary my good friend became the head of
this task force and her role became
politicized from the very beginning and
she could never escape no matter how
hard she tried or whether she wished to
from being a political figure from the
very start in Bosnia President Clinton
learned after two years that it required
his strong continued and persistent
attention and he learned that diplomacy
backed by Forest was the way to go but
it took him that long to gain command
and learned how to operate in foreign
policy in health care we know that the
health care initiative met division
among the Democrats never gained the
support that it ought to have was
postponed time and again as the
president pursued other initiatives that
also divided the Democrats even positive
initiatives free trade crime bill gun
control all these divided the Democrats
have up and down the line and health
care never came to a vote on the floor
of the Senate and thus was defeated in
the middle of all this there
was a fostering of what I would call
pseudo scandals this was created by a
cast of characters from underneath a
rock some of them coming from far from
Clinton's Arkansas years cast of
characters that included all sorts of
right-wing operatives in even diehard
old segregationists from beginning of
time and they create they began with
with white water white water is seemed
so incomprehensible now it's a murky
complex endless scandal but it's an
important one because it became the
German that led to the plague of the
impeachment trial white water can be
described in one sentence in 1978 Bill
and Hillary Clinton invested in a real
estate deal and lost all their money
that's the beginning in the end of the
story there's nothing more to it but it
led to the appointment of an independent
counsel and soon that initial
independent counsel a moderate
Republican named Robert Fisk was
replaced when the Independent Counsel
Act had to be renewed and he was
replaced by the three-judge conservative
dominated panel that appointed
independent counsels and Kenneth W star
was appointed in his place star was
inexperienced a weak man in my view
sought to be tough and was a deeply
partisan and he began looking into the
whitewater scandal I learned later and
doing my book in talking to was Sam dash
who some of you may remember from the
days when he was chief counsel or the
Watergate committee and he became the
legal counselor to Ken Starr he looked
into the prosecution memos of all of
these pseudo scandals travel office the
FBI files whitewater and he told me on
the record they had nothing and he went
to Ken Starr and he told him it's your
job after all these years of looking
into this to drop it because you're a
professional now and when you find no
evidence it's your due diligence
to write such a report and star refused
because he believed that the Clintons
must be guilty it was an article of
faith with him they must be guilty
because the less evidence he found he
said the more they must be covering up
and so whitewater continued and
whitewater also bore on what happened
here in this first Clinton war rush
limbaugh was the one who let the cat out
of the bag when he said whitewater is
about health care because by creating
these pseudo scandals the Republicans
and the right-wing hoped to stop
President Clinton's progressive program
that's why they were started and created
and fostered and soon there were legends
and myths President Clinton was even
accused of murdering dozens of people
there were rumors of all sorts and and
yet in the midst of all this there were
great achievements for example on the
economy President Clinton took a tough
presidential decision he decided once he
learned that the economy was that the
budget was going far deeper into deficit
than he had been told before by the
outgoing Bush administration that he had
to reduce the deficit and in his first
budget a tough budget that raised taxes
on the uppermost rate not a single
Republican supported it in the house or
the Senate and Al Gore as vice president
had to break the tie in the Senate to
approve that budget which reduce the
deficit by three quarters and set in
motion acted as the catalyst for the
greatest prosperity of the country has
ever known yet all of this even the
great successes created a burden on the
Democrats and that led to the election
of the Republicans in both houses of
Congress they gain control and soon
there arose a figure as Speaker of the
House who thought he was the head of
state higher than the president master
of the universe as he put a teacher of
civilization Newt king
rich Gingrich practice to politics of
annihilation he believed that his
opponents were not simply in opposition
but an enemy he called Bill Clinton the
enemy of normal Americans and he
announced publicly that every committee
of Congress should be turned into an
investigative body and in the end more
than 30 committees and subcommittees
were investigating the Clinton
administration this was the single
greatest initiative of the Republican
Congress and in the end they turned up
no wrongdoing Newt Gingrich shut down
the Congress twice believing he could
intimidate the President and thereby
pave the way for a Republican to gain
the white house again drive clinton from
office but President Clinton did not
give in to newt gingrich in shutting
down the government and instead the
public turned against the Republican
Congress led by Gingrich Gingrich also
had another problem and that will happen
to be his personal relationship with
Bill Clinton because Clinton understood
Gingrich in a way the Gingrich never
understood Clinton in this second
Clinton warm and in this war Bill
Clinton understood that Newt Gingrich
actually was an insecure person even of
1960s countercultural wannabe though he
talked hum about how much he condemned
the 1960s he actually wanted to be
accepted so Bill Clinton put his big arm
around him and he would talk to Newt
Gingrich for hours he would talk to him
about public policy and national
security and Gingrich would find himself
nodding and agreeing with the president
and he would go back to the house
republican conference and he would tell
them what he had agreed to that he had
negotiated something reasonable with
President Clinton and they staged a
revolt against him and they even tried
to get rid of him Gingrich said to them
and this is all recorded here he said
you don't know what it's like to be
alone with him
you do the same thing so the Republicans
decided Gingrich should never be alone
with Bill Clinton
and they sent from then on a minder to
accompany him to the White House and
this minder was Dick Armey he's a tough
babysitter and so bill clinton won
reelection and it was then that he asked
me to join the White House as his
assistant and senior adviser and that
whole story is recounted here at the
beginning of his second term bill
clinton was about to usher the budget
into surplus for the first time in
decades we were about to make great
investments in education health care in
the environment we were preparing for a
great state of the union address in
which all the departments and agencies
were funneling in their proposals and
ideas we'd already made great gains
family medical leave tens of millions of
Americans were able to well now to be
able to take care of their families or
their children when they needed to and
not suffer on their job there had been
the hope scholarships passed more than
10 million young people could now go to
college on these scholarships that
hadn't been able to take advantage of
them before but there was much more to
do much much more to do so we were
preparing for that bill clinton who i
saw now no longer is a journalist on the
outside but on the inside as his advisor
was somebody who was involved from
beginning to end in every single public
policy every single decision that was
taken he was profoundly involved in he
did not operate from a small circle of
closed advisers one never knew who
President Clinton was talking to he had
on any given issue ranging from the
Middle East to education a wide range of
acquaintances friends some of you whom
are in this room today who he would draw
upon for information he not getting out
in the country and talking to people and
he would learn by speaking to people I
found that in any room and that we were
in when he was being briefed on almost
any issue he was as expert as the
greatest expert in the room he would
rewrite every single speech and he would
then once he was relaxed regale his
advisors with tall tales from Arkansas
before he would deliver them about how
he was going to once have a shootout
with the NRA lobbyist that sort of thing
and then he would sombrely deliver his
speeches we were all set to do that when
i remember on january 21st 1998 another
Clinton war broke out this was a war
between President Clinton and the
Independent Counsel Kenneth W star and
on starside I would say was the vast
right-wing conspiracy and anyone who
reads this book will never be able to
deny that they were there and how they
operated the day the Monica Lewinsky
story broke in the Washington Post I
read it on my doorstep at 6am it accused
the president of serious crimes
subordination of perjury and obstruction
of justice in a conspiracy with Vernon
Jordan a great civil rights leader
Washington lawyer close personal friend
of the President and I ran into the
White House every single day before 9am
I had four meetings and this time
instead of everybody being very focused
and efficient and effective as we always
were I found a good deal of confusion
and chaos let me just read you a little
bit about what the atmosphere was like
inside the White House on that day that
first day of this what became a great
constitutional crisis within the White
House there was no organizing focus no
strategy no one calling meetings and we
had a growing sense of standing on a
beach waiting for a title
wave some felt near panic those are my
colleagues my fellow advisers President
Clinton normally poised political people
believe they faced potential personal
ruin they correctly thought that ken
starr's power was limitless and his
motive to destroy the president
relentless they'd convinced themselves
even if they had no reason that they too
would become stars targets their fear
was dark and it was seeping out to
reporters the plague that had gone
through chronic and acute phases from
the beginning of Clinton's
administration was now extremely acute
but as sudden and all-encompassing as
the crisis was its elements were not
unknown to us for years there had been
accusations congressional hearings and
stars grand juries there had been
prosecutorial links and raging fire
storms over white water with Hillary
herself drag past the klieg lights to
testify the entire scandal system was
already in order all the actors from
start ticking grid's from the reporters
to the talking heads on television were
on their well-rehearsed marks the plague
now arrived in full force and the whole
political city was consumed by delirium
and that is what we faced on the first
day how did we resolve it how did we
think how did we come to any ability to
act along with the other members of the
senior staff we held in constant
discussions and developed our own
strategies of course we had doubts about
whether or not there was a private
relationship but about whether or not
there were crimes committed against his
public office I had no doubts that this
was false and I had no doubts that Ken
Starr was acting as a reckless partisan
prosecutor operating not on the idea of
American jurisprudence but more on the
idea of an inquisition in which a man is
targeted in search of a crime and in the
balance I believed and so did the others
on the staff that whatever existed in
the personal life of the President it
belonged not to us and it wasn't about
us it belonged to the Clintons it was
about them and about their marriage and
for them to resolve not for us on the
other hand there was what we regarded as
an assault on the President on his
program on the institution of the
presidency and ultimately on the
Constitution itself so for us the
decision was clear we decided we would
stand with the president we also
respected him as a man and we knew that
his private political values in public
were the same as in private it's not one
of us not one person left the White
House throughout this ordeal not one we
all stood by the president together as
an effective team I found that I was
subpoenaed myself kenstar was very very
angry he was very angry for several
reasons one he was angry because the
American people had figured out how to
deal with this in pretty much the same
way we had on the senior staff we had to
figure it out earlier but the American
people figured it out fairly quickly
that what mattered to them was the
president's job performance and whether
or not he'd committed any crime against
his office and they decided he had not
and they decided that if this was a
private matter it belonged to him and so
they supported him and more than
two-thirds of the American people
constantly supported him
out this ordeal kenstar was angry
because Hillary Clinton went on the NBC
Today Show and said if anyone's looking
for a good story they ought to examine
this vast right-wing conspiracy and I
know that Ken start wanted to rush on to
TV and yell at her then and I have it in
my book there was in fact a vast
right-wing conspiracy it involved a
dirty-tricks campaign financed by the
Daddy Warbucks of the far right Richard
melons gave multi-million dollars there
was a there was a collusion between the
right-wing operatives who were pulling
the strings of the Paul Jones case a
case thrown out by the judge ultimately
is lacking all Merritt and they colluded
with members of ken starr's office so
that he could expand his pro from his
dead whitewater investigation into the
Lewinsky matter and charged the
president with serious crimes crimes
that the president was ultimately
acquitted on and there was a vast
right-wing conspiracy in the Congress
itself there were Republicans in the
Congress were so intent on damaging the
president in trying to stop his program
that they were willing to sacrifice to
speakers of the house in their effort
against Clinton they were willing to
lose both Newt Gingrich and Bob
Livingston to their own personal
scandals they didn't care it was a price
they were willing to pay and the person
who was behind that and driving the
impeachment was Tom DeLay the House
Republican whip later the House
Republican leader
and Tom DeLay was the one who really
drove this impeachment forward he
coerced members of the Republican Party
to vote for it whether they wanted to or
not and I wanted to read you a little
bit from my book about what Tom DeLay
did because I think it's very important
Tom DeLay I'm staff to find it here I
have this book all marked up here it is
we were in the White House and we were
counting votes about whether or not
Republicans would vote for impeachment
we believe that moderate Republicans
would vote against impeachment
particularly after the midterm election
when republicans lost seats because
Gingrich had pushed the impeachment
issue and the American people had
rejected it we thought that democracy
may have sent a message but we were
wrong we heard from Republicans that's
those of us in the White House working
on this matter that Tom DeLay's
operation was putting pressure on the
campaign finance chairman of certain
individual congressmen in one case we
learned a congressman's brother had been
called and told to influence his brother
who would otherwise face a right-wing
opponent in the two thousand primary
representative a mo ho a moderate
Republican from New York who opposed
impeachment had already been declared a
betrayer and a conservative primary
opponent had announced against him even
though it was two years to the election
this was an obvious demonstration case
to encourage the others potent wasn't
heir to the Corning Glass fortune in
self financing but other Republicans
were not in his protected position
Representative Peter King a Republican
of New York who also opposed impeachment
was threatened with being stripped of a
sub committee chairmanship an aide to
delay warned him that the whip would
make the next two years the longest of
his life well congressman King told me
later coming out of the election
everyone thought impeach
was dead I didn't hear anyone discuss
impeachment it was over then delay
assumed control delay used the 81
questions these were a series of
interrogatories that the Republicans
posed to the president strictly for
demagogic reasons to try and whip up
public opposition to him and it gave him
a Peggy needed in most districts in the
country a majority was against
impeachment maybe a majority of
Republicans but a majority who voted in
Republican primaries was for impeachment
when you put individual members under
the gun a lot of them could get killed
in a primary that was the way he did it
I heard of Christian radio stations
going after Republicans right-wing
groups were stirring it up in parts of
the country outside of the Northeast
most of the pressure went through the
Christian Right networks it happened
over a ten-day period the home world
change I remember talking to people like
Rick Lazio and Mike Forbes both
Republicans of New York and they were
saying this is nuts then suddenly they
were holding news conferences saying
their consciences were torn on December
15th nine previously uncommitted
Republican moderates announced from
impeachment as my friend James Carville
says a moderate Republican is someone
who's moderate when Tom DeLay medicine
I was called as a witness as the third
and final witness in this Senate trial
of the president I'd already been
subpoenaed by Ken Starr I was subpoenaed
not because I had any information about
Monica Lewinsky who I'd never heard of
before never met but I had been talking
to reporters being a member of the press
and I was critical of Ken Starr he
wanted to intimidate his critics he was
leaking to favored reporters in the
Washington press corps and creating his
own personal core of reporters who were
dependent upon him and whose career
careers were now rising as a result of
having his exclusives which consisted of
uncorroborated rumors often false what
he was doing was in violation of the
code of federal prosecutors but suddenly
other reporters step forward and other
columnist and they began to be critical
so starting issued a subpoena to me the
White House legal counsel told me it was
the most astonishing subpoena he'd ever
seen because it demanded to know all of
my contacts with members of the media he
demanded my phone logs of every
conversation I've ever had with a
reporter and I had to turn them over
which I did afterwards I would after
being brought into the grand jury as a
witness I learned that I could make a
public statement and I did I had seen
other members of the White House staff
treated poorly in my view I did not
appreciate the way Betty curry had been
treated or many other members of the
White House staff who had been
browbeaten and dragged before this grand
jury and so I went out in courthouse
steps and said if they think they've
intimidated me they have failed this
turned public opinion in part against
our and the right wing and ken starr's
office and the reporters who were
beholden to him launched a campaign
against me I became a lightning rod
because I stood by the President and
subsequently i was called as a witness
in the impeachment trial in the Senate
room where I was to be questioned by the
house managers acting as the prosecutors
presenting their case before the Senate
I waited and they walked in I was to be
questioned by Jim Rogan among others one
of the house managers a former
prosecutor himself and as I stood there
about to take my seat behind the table
and swear an oath Rogan came up to me
and he said you know no one wants to be
here less than you except me and I said
really Jim he said that's right because
were on the wrong side of history and I
was astonished it was not only an
admission that they would lose
politically which was a foregone
conclusion when it was clear that many
Senate Republicans wanted no part of
what the extreme Republicans in the
House had done under tongue delays
coercive whim but it was also an
admission that there was something wrong
here in the end the president was
acquitted of all charges I remember the
political strategy meeting we held we
used to hold them every week in the
what's called the yellow oval office and
you can see a picture of it in this
library it's a beautiful picture of it
and we would sit around and discuss
political strategy Michael Waldman who
was our chief speechwriter said at the
end of the meeting mr. president he said
I've been watching cable TV all day and
their new scandals on Clinton said don't
worry they're just reloading voice
we fought real wars we fought a war in
kosovo that settled the peace in Europe
we kept the Western alliance together
was a difficult difficult political task
and then we were back to the Clinton
Ward's again at home and the last
Clinton war was the election of two
thousand I hope that all Democrats
running for office in 2004 will read my
chapter on Al Gore and that election
although Al Gore made tactical errors in
his campaign he was someone I worked
with and came to know inside the White
House he was an incredibly productive
vice president who worked on public
policy ranging from a reinventing
government to putting global warming
forward as an issue to working on
us-russian relations advancing democracy
and stabilizing it they're working on
trade issues working on technology
issues it was a great innovator and even
a futurist he was a dedicated public
servant he devoted virtually his entire
life to public service and came from a
family who had given their lives his
mother and father both to public service
his father as you know had been senator
from Tennessee before him and his mother
had worked for Eleanor Roosevelt writing
her correspondence but Al Gore who was
an Eagle Scout did not run consistently
on the Clinton record I believe that he
was disoriented by the campaign against
President Clinton although no one
confused al gore personally with Bill
Clinton and his human foibles gore could
have run on the record more consistently
and there was a disinformation campaign
against gore now this is very
interesting because all along
there'd been a very very focused
campaign against President Clinton and
against Hillary Clinton against both the
Clintons and suddenly Al Gore became the
focus of this attack machine this Eagle
Scout this person of sterling integrity
how could this happen and what did they
do they went to the core of his
character and attacked him as a liar and
exaggerator on stories that every single
one is I document in the book were
themselves lies and exaggerations but
gore was so offended and had such a
sense of himself and knew that he was a
person of integrity that he did not
respond right away to these attacks he
was disoriented by the disinformation I
believe and so it was beneath his
dignity to reply to these scurrilous
attacks and so they stuck and in the end
only fifty-seven percent of those who
agreed with Al Gore on the issues wound
up voting form in the second debate Jim
lair who is a fair man and a fine
journalist devoted the entire last
segment of that debate to whether or not
Al Gore was a liar an exaggerator
putting Gore in the defense of any lost
15 points just from that debate alone a
completely false issue so it turned out
that it wasn't just about Bill Clinton
the person and it wasn't just about Al
Gore the person or Hillary the person it
had to do with the kind of politics that
they practiced and the kind of programs
that they had and the goals that they
pursued it was really about who would
hold the presidency who would hold power
and whether or not the progressive
presidency would be continued in the end
Gore won despite all this he won by more
than 500,000 votes he won by more than
five times the amount that John F
Kennedy beat Richard Nixon
and he certainly won florida the u.s
Civil Rights Commission in fact
investigated after the election what had
happened in Florida and it issued a
report an undeniable irrefutable report
saying that the majority of those votes
that were not counted in Florida in
which the intent of the voter was clear
were cast by african-americans so what
began in the 1992 campaign as an attack
on Bill Clinton involving some of the
old diehard segregationists from his
Arkansas wound up in Florida in the
greatest violation of voting rights
since the era of Jim Crow the only vote
that counted was 524 in the Supreme
Court with the conservative majority
giving the presidency to george w bush
but the era is not over and a legacy has
hardly ended there many lessons to be
learned here their lessons in policy
lessons about to begin with economic
management that was a tough decision
President Clinton took beginning in 1993
and there were tough decisions all along
the way to save Social Security and make
it solvent for the retirement of the
baby boom generation to extend Medicare
and devote the surplus to that 22
million new jobs lowest unemployment
rates since President Johnson greatest
rise in living standards of
african-americans since the end of Jim
Crow twenty five percent reduction in
poverty that's the greatest fallen
poverty since the administration of
President Johnson in in in foreign
policy President Clinton established a
new internationalism in the post-cold
war era in which we worked with our
allies and extended our alliance and won
Wars yes and build up our military in
fact it was this military that won the
wars in Afghanistan and Iraq and this
internationalism
understood that in the new global
economy what was required was not only
free and open trade but also raised
Labor Standards new initiatives for
women women's rights we lowered the debt
unless developed nations by three
quarters at the 1999 g8 summit in
cologne we had education initiatives for
the third world we understood that it
that we that we had to deal with the
disparities and the inequalities and the
disequilibrium zin this new global
economy that we were facing or else
there would be new perils including the
president said terrorism and he fought a
war against Al Qaeda tried to kill bin
Laden missing him by only hours after
the East African bombings in august of
1998 world of terrorist cells stopped
the millennium bombings of two thousand
and extensively briefed the incoming
bush team that terrorism would be the
greatest problem that they would face
President Clinton also advanced the idea
of one America not simply as an ideal
but as a practicality I believe he did
more on this count in creating an image
of our country as one nation of people
from diverse backgrounds than anyone
since President Johnson and he did it
through policies that worked he
practiced the politics of hope and
possibility he did it in a practical way
he did not exploit the politics of fear
and insecurity and politically he also
showed that if you stand up for yourself
people will know that you will stand up
for them you know it the presidency is a
representative office in a democracy and
it's crucial to stand up to those who
would oppose you and your program and
use any means to try and stop it it's a
legacy that Democrats I believe or two
ought to follow and finally there's
another lesson it's a lesson that I saw
by standing next to President Clinton
and that is a very
very important lesson it's related to
the question of hope and that is that
presidents matter presidents really
matter who was president it mattered
that President Johnson was there we saw
it in the lives of every American and
that's why we're a different and better
nation today even today we wouldn't be
what we are today if he had not been
there and the same is true for President
Clinton in his own way he reanimated the
progressive tradition in the presidency
and he made us a better people and the
American people ultimately were the ones
who chose that path because they put
them in the White House but presidents
matter and those who say that presidents
don't matter have another agenda they
want to encourage apathy and despair and
make it seem that you don't count they
want to make you feel that the economy
is the weather and presidents can't
affect it they're just business cycles
and they go up and they go down and
there may be unfair policies and tax
cuts that benefit the wealthy but that's
just how they're how it is and you
shouldn't worry about presidents
affecting things in improving a lot of
the majority because they can't do that
but they really mean is that they want
to hold the power and they want to make
the decisions because they know to the
president's matter so from President
Clinton President Johnson president
kennedy president truman president
roosevelt and all the way down to the
beginning there have been progressive
presence who've shown the president's
matter and take hard decisions and tough
decisions that change our country for
the better ultimately it's all about us
at the end of my book i quote a poem
from walt whitman who was a great
admirer of a republican progressive
president abraham lincoln and in this
poem Whitman says you are not there for
the president
the president is in the White House for
you and that's what we all know about
progressive presidents and that's what I
learned being in the Clinton White House
thank you very much I'd like to answer
your question
thank you I believe if you go to the
microphones their microphone setup
there's one right over there if anyone
has a question and there's one right
over there in that aisle on the day that
George W Bush moved into the White House
there was a big story about the
so-called trashing of the White House by
you all I'm I'm wondering what has
happened to the press corps that
apparently none of them said show me
none of them said I want to go over and
sit with my own eyes and it turned out
that that was all a phony story but it
was played for days and days and days
and a lot of people bought it I'm
wondering if you can comment on members
of the White House press corps that they
just take handouts incidentally that
story came from an anonymous source in
the White House no one was willing to
put their and attach their name to that
story but what's become of the press
corps that they don't say I want to look
at it and see it for myself and the
other question I'd like to ask is could
you comment on Tom DeLay's participation
in the immediate aftermath of a november
two thousand election when he arranged
to send all the republican congressional
staffers down to florida to create to
stop the hand recount that was taking
place and to create what was considered
to be the best-dressed riot that's ever
occurred in this country
so those are two good questions small
questions the on the first one the the
press corps large parts of it had become
compliant with the scandal mongering of
the right as they advance their careers
I believe in the Clinton administration
they also believe that they proved
somehow how independent and brave they
were the more they trash the Clinton
administration there's some degree of
competitiveness with Clinton and with
those of us in the Clinton White House
from elements of the press court why is
that so that's so because we weren't
privileged we weren't sons of privilege
we were people who got there for the
most part on merit and just were
educated and worked to get in these
positions that's very much like the
Washington press corps for the most part
and I heard more than one reporters say
you know why are they there well you
know I'm just as smart I should be here
it was a very competitive feeling
whereas there is a deferential feeling a
different class feeling towards some
Republicans who are privileged and
there's a distance and they don't see
them as the same as themselves and so
they're more deferential they also
believe in a perverse way that they can
prove their objectivity and independence
by trashing Democrats somehow because
they've been attacked by the Republicans
as the liberal media and they can prove
they're not and on the other hand they
can prove that they're fair by leaning
over backwards for the Republicans so
there's a certain psychology to all of
this that story about trashing the white
house was completely a false I was in
the White House until the last day i was
actually with president clinton as the
oval office was being packed up into
boxes and i saw what went on it was
there was no such thing as what was
described in the press now on Tom DeLay
Tom baghalet in the Florida contest
rounded up along with trent lott and his
congressional staffers and a bunch of
other republican congressional staffers
they gone on playing some of them paid
for by Enron and Halliburton private
jets they went down to Florida and they
went into Miami Dade County they went
down to the county a courthouse where
the supervisors were beginning to count
the boat there and as we know that would
have added hundreds of votes to Al
Gore's column because we know now what
that vote would have been and they
literally stage to riot and stop the
counting of the votes they push people
around they even physically attacked
County Supervisors there who felt
intimidated and stopped counting and it
was never resumed so the vote counting
was stopped by physical violence the
Republicans in Florida were willing to
use any means necessary to stop the
boats from being counted before their
case reached the Supreme Court and on
the one hand you've got to admire them
they were willing to do anything it was
all hands on deck they actually cared
about power and on the other hand you
have to remember that's what they'll do
there's something that's been a question
I've been wanting to ask for ten years
something that I regret very much when
the whole debate about health care began
my late husband became very interested
and had many ideas on the subject and we
we both thought that we were sure that
there would be some improvement Lee
after the debacle after hiring Louise
one out why why did the Clintons not say
well maybe our program was too
complicated maybe it should be different
but by golly we're going to stick to the
goal of universal healthcare they didn't
and I will never understand why they
didn't go on saying that I think now
it's going to be ten times harder it's a
very important question and the answer
has to do with the politics of the time
and how the Clinton Wars
evolved the when the universal health
care plan was defeated President Clinton
bully and the and the Democrats lost
control of the Congress president
clinton had to outsmart and outfox the
republicans and he needed a new strategy
he could not simply propose universal
health care as a rhetorical statement
and see it defeated again and again and
again and look as though he were
ineffective he had to have proposals on
which he could corner the Republicans
wrong foot them if you will and then
keep moving and moving and moving
incrementally and he did so even on
health care he never gave up on this
goal but he knew that he could never
implement it but we did implement
portability of health care in the in the
even after the defeat of the universal
health care plan so that workers could
take their health care plan with them
from job to job we implemented
children's health insurance program that
covered five million poor children so we
made some gains some incremental gains
but one of the one of the legacies here
is that there's a large unfinished
agenda all presidents however great
their achievements leave unfinished
agendas President Johnson left one
President Truman left one it was
President Truman who first proposed
universal health care and we didn't
achieve it and that's going to be left
to a future president so there's much
left to do and that's one of the lessons
here and there's a huge huge program
that we have to take up and it's going
to meet with new realities as well and a
new progressive president sometime in
the future is going to have to shape
that program and meet these new
realities in a new way drawing on this
tradition not only of the right values
but of innovation and
Emmett ISM in order to accomplish it
because politics as we all know is the
art of the possible and we all try and
get as much as we can and I believe
that's what President Clinton did under
the circumstances and I believe that's
what President Johnson did when he had
that wonderful landslide in 1964 and was
able to accomplish so much for the
American people that had been thwarted
before in the first term under President
Kennedy so as much as as was done much
is left to be done Al Gore has said he
won't run for president do you think he
could be drafted and persuaded to run
and would he win if he did I believe I
take al gore his word I think he's not
running I think the desire for Democrats
to draft Gore shows that the Democrats
who were in the field right now need to
have more appeal to the rank-and-file
Democrats they need to speak up they
need to draw in sharper a contrast
between their program and what George
Bush is doing and they need to end it's
going to be a long process because the
Democratic primaries are going to take
place now over many many months and it's
not going to be until next year that
there's a single nominee a single voice
for the Democratic Party it's going to
be very frustrating for Democrats but
it's inevitable and the desire that
either President Clinton descend from
the heavens somehow and assume the role
as spokesman or that Hillary run which
is not running or that Al Gore be
drafted when he's made plain that just
isn't running this time I think only
adds to the frustration but also should
leap Democrats themselves to demand that
their candidates speak up actually by
the question was about the 2004 campaign
why as everyone knows Al Gore won the
popular vote I'm just kind of surprised
I is not getting in a 2004 race and I
know mrs. Clinton's I know your friend
of hers and her name's come up and she's
been actually showing very high in the
polls for 2004 so I'm wondering where
her future is and I'm kind of surprised
that you know she's very high up there
when the 2004 her name comes up and this
wandering away you know Gore's kind of
been kind of a quiet and its owner mrs.
Clinton's future holds because I'm very
surprised she's high in the 2004 pole so
I'm wondering if she's not actually run
thank you I think that Senator Clinton
Hillary Clinton is capable knowledgeable
experienced his few people are in the
presidency and she's learned a lot from
the time she headed the healthcare task
force to the time she want to see in the
US Senate to represent New York and
we're now in the Senate she reaches
across the aisle and many Republicans
regard her as extremely effective and
not at all as the stereotype that they
had thought they'd find her to be a very
different kind of human being also I
hope everyone here reads her book as
well it's a complementary book to this
volume and I think it's very important
that there be other books as well many
books about this period so when we try
and lay claim to the future we also we
understand we what the past was because
it's crucial that we know where we were
so that we know where we're going
Hillary is not running this time and
what I'd like to say is that she will
endorse the incumbent Democratic
president for reelection in 2008
but if some indefinite time in the
future it should ever happen that she
were somehow to run and become president
I have no doubt that she'd be a fine
president we here in travis county
seemed to be in a redistricting battle
with Tom DeLay it seems to be directly
with tom delay and i wonder if you could
tell us what you have learned about how
to do battle with this person
I hope the Democrats can win this battle
I hope that the demo the Texas
Democratic senators hold firm and none
of them defect that they all stand up
for democracy because it's crucial here
in Texas that they do that but I also
believe that this is a fight that is
being watched by Democrats across the
country I think that they are watching
Texas Democrats stand up this is a tough
state for them it's a lot tougher than
some other states in the country this is
in California it's not Illinois and its
not New York for Democrats but it might
be sometime in the future there are
profound changes going on in the
composition of the population of Texas
and sometime in the future it may just
be that especially with the growth of
Hispanic voters and with their growing
participation in the electorate that
Texas to could find itself becoming a
lot more like California and voting
consistently Democratic sometime in the
future and I believe that's the motive
behind what Tom DeLay is doing and I
believe he's working with Karl Rove and
and that's why they want to
redistricting of redistricting make it
very difficult in the future when it and
what they want to do is sort the will of
the people now and in the future and
they want to establish conditions that
do that so I think if you stand up now
you send a message to Democrats not only
here but in the country I think if you
stand up now you're also putting in a
marker for the future that will bear
fruit for Democrats when conditions
change which inevitably they will this
will pass this too shall pass
I certainly hope that you recommend that
your statement that this too shall pass
will come true but this goes back to I
don't think it's lighter but it might be
i did a doctoral dissertation on first
ladies in the White House and you know
almost every one of them had husbands
who cheated on almost every one of them
now why maybe there is a strive for
domination for power for intellect or
whatever but why do we make so much of
it when it is so regular
boy that's a tough question when you
understand I'm going to answer in my
capacity as former advisor I would say
that as I said before this really
belongs between two people it's about
them doesn't belong in politics we have
the confluence of peculiar factors in
the Clinton presidency with an
unaccountable Independent Counsel
running amok had we not had that office
I don't believe that this matter which
never properly belongs in the public
arena would have been turned into a
constitutional crisis countries had
never been put through it and I believe
also the president should not have been
asked these questions na as a result of
a wretched Supreme Court decision saying
that he could be subjected to a civil
suit even by a clearly a politically
driven case that was thrown out as
lacking merit because it wouldn't
distract him from his public performance
which we know was ridiculous worse than
a bright sexy president
I'm not even going to follow up on that
and that got Betty Sue out of her chair
thanks for an interesting spirited
evening sidney blumenthal and we'd like
to invite you all of you upstairs to the
reception thank you